اصوات المعتقلين الاجانب في ايران بدات
تطلب النجده اياما بعد اعدام النظام
الايراني للبريطاني رضا اكبر بتهمه التجسس
متهم اخر بالتجسس بدا يحاول نفذ بجده
ومغادره السجون الايرانيه والحديث هنا عن
الامريكي سياميك نازيك الاخيره اعلن بدء
اضراب عن الطعام لللفت انتباه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن للتحرك للافراج عنه
وقال سيامي كمازي في رساله المفتوحه ان جل
ما يطلبه من الرئيس هو تكاليس دقيقه من
وقته في الايام المقبله لمئات الرهائن
الامريكيين في ايران
[موسيقى]
وهي في اعلان ماضي عن الاضراب عن الطعام
في ذكرى الافراج عن خمسه امريكيين في
العام 2016 وكان ذلك في اطار البرنامج
النووي الايراني الذي تم تعليقه في من بعد
ويبقى ملف الرهين الامريكيين والاجانب
بشكل من بين او يشكل من بين الملفات
الخارجيه الهامه المطروحه على طاوله
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه وهو ما كان دفعه
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه الى الاعلاني
قبل اسابيع لبذل مجهودات للتواصل الى حل
للافراج عن المواطنين الامريكيين
المعتقلين في ايران
سجن ايفين الذي يقضي فيه نمازي عقوبته يضم
ايضا العديد من السجناء الاجانب التي تم
توجيه تهم مختلف اليهم من بينهم عماد شرقي
وهو رجل اعمال ايراني امريكي ومحكوم عليه
بالسجن 10 سنوات بتهمه التخابر هناك ايضا
مراد طهباز وهو ناشط بيئي ايراني امريكي
الجنسيه ايضا ويحمل الجنسيه البريطانيه
كذلك وحكم عليه بالسجن 10 سنوات بتهمه
التواضع على امن ايران القومي في سجن
ايفين ايضا النشطه الحقوقيه الالمانيه
الايرانيه والتي حكم عليها بالسجن 10
سنوات بيتها من متعلقه بالامن القومي كما
يقبع في السجن ايضا احمد رضا جلال وهو
طبيب سويدي الايراني حكم عليه بالاعدام
بتهمه التجسس لصالح اسرائيل